foreign
it is a commonly used acronym that in
Britain stands for that Nigel
farage but in this country it stands for
temporary assistance for needy families
a federal program designed to help
families with little to no income TANF
is an absolutely vital resource and also
the program underneath Mississippi's
spectacular ongoing scandals involving
former quarterback Brett Favre NFL Hall
of Famer Brett Favre is under growing
pressure tonight as a new court filing
says the former football star waged a
campaign to aggressively Lobby for
millions of dollars from the state
welfare agency to finish building a
volleyball facility at his alma mater
the University of Southern Mississippi
where his daughter played the sport
that's right Brett Favre was involved in
getting five million dollars in tariff
funds funneled into building this
volleyball stadium and I'm a little
surprised you even need a stadium to
play volleyball in I thought it was a
sport mainly played Outdoors by sexually
frustrated men who aren't wearing shirts
and sporty dogs who unexpectedly are but
clearly I was wrong about that but false
role in this Scandal went far beyond
just volleyball he's also alleged to
have helped get around 2 million of TANF
dollars routed to a pharmaceutical
company that he invested in and
personally received over a million more
for the promise that he'd make public
appearances or record PSAs and in his
text messages to a central figure in the
scheme a woman named Nancy new father
seemed eager to keep the details of this
deal private Tech show Farr was worried
about how it might look he wrote If you
were to pay me is there any way the
media can find out where it came from
and how much new replied no but added I
understand you being uneasy about that
yeah me too but Brett I have some
terrible news for you the media did find
out that's what's happening now
of the story is just the tip of the
iceberg here because amazingly from 2016
to 2019 at least 77 million dollars in
federal welfare money was stolen or
misspent in Mississippi six people have
been criminally charged so far with most
pleading guilty including the former
director of the state's welfare agency
this Scandal is full of both bizarre
details and a weird number of former
athletes including retired WWE wrestler
Ted The Million Dollar Man DiBiase seen
here in his Heyday looking very cool
dvrc Annie's Ministry apparently
received nearly two million dollars to
among other things creates a phone app
to reach troubled teens and send them
Bible verses something that apparently
never happened which is probably just as
well given that it's hard to imagine
this man helping any teen who is in
trouble unless the thing they're having
trouble with is figuring out what it
would look like if Steven Seagal somehow
aged even worse
and look legally I have to tell you that
both valve and dbse maintained they did
nothing wrong and have not been
criminally charged and fav wants us to
tell you that he returns the 1.1 million
that he was personally paid and says
that he didn't know any of the money was
coming from welfare funds although it's
not clear exactly where exactly he did
think the money was coming from perhaps
he thinks there's some pot of taxpayer
money they can just dip his sausage
fingers into whenever he needs something
I don't know he's been hit in the head a
lot not enough but a lot but what is not
in dispute here is that for years there
were people in Mississippi in dire need
of help who just couldn't get it Tamara
Edwards raised four children on her own
in Mississippi applying for welfare
benefits just once for child care while
she worked when I reapplied
I was not able to be on it
again because they told me that they
didn't have the fundings for it that is
pretty infuriating to hear and it gets
even worse when you learn that in
Mississippi last year of roughly 190 000
children living in poverty just 2600
were receiving money from TANF while
remember of the roughly one Brett
Favre's in Mississippi 100 percent of
them managed to get five million dollars
for this volleyball Stadium it's
enough to make you want to see Brett
Favre hitting the nuts with a football
and the good news is I can actually help
you there things on practice field this
week and got hit in the not so friendly
area oh it takes them all the way down
I'm glad that happened a brother like
two notes in the local news team for
adding the Boeing sound effect there
excellent journalism but it is important
to know that while what happened in
Mississippi Rose to criminal charges in
States all over the country the TANF
program has been abused for decades and
completely legally in fact Nationwide
for every 100 families in poverty only
21 receive TANF cash assistance meaning
we have a program that is supposed to
give money to families in desperate need
and four out of five of them just aren't
getting it so tonight let's talk about
TANF and let's start with why it is so
important TANF is the only Federal
anti-poverty program that provides
monthly cash assistance that makes it
very different from say snap you know
formerly known as food stamps because
that can only be used to pay for food
whereas tan of funds by contrast can be
used for all sorts of other necessities
from diapers to toothpaste to utility
bills so it can be an absolute Lifeline
for families and the truth is we have
long known just how important cash
assistance can be in 1935 FDR pushed for
the A2 dependent children program and
back then the idea had broad support the
welfare of a Nation depends upon the
welfare of its children to provide for
children who have lost their
Breadwinners the state and federal
governments provide monthly cash
payments so that these children may grow
up at home with their own families aid
for children who are citizens of
Tomorrow need the security of home today
wow it is genuinely refreshing to hear
that kind of voice saying such nice
things although given the time I am
guessing that he just kept talking he
would have said something like also
nothing calms a hysterical child like a
good smack with a stick
that program continued to have support
for years while perhaps not
coincidentally it was primarily white
families like those you just saw who
were the ones using it but as Barry's
preventing black family from
participating began to fall people
suddenly began to panic about whether
these programs might actually encourage
laziness and dependency and to use
America's official slogan Ronald Reagan
made it worse because conservatives in
the 70s and 80s led by Reagan pushed
largely or cherry-picked
narratives of Fraud and Abuse it got to
the point where by the mid 90s one
Florida representative found this a
completely acceptable way to talk about
welfare recipients WE Post these signs
for several reasons first because if
left in a natural state alligators can
fend for themselves they work gather
food and care for their young
secondly WE Post These Warnings because
unnatural feeding and artificial care
creates dependency when dependency sets
in these otherwise abled alligators can
no longer survive on their own I know
people are not alligators but I submit
to you that with our current handout
non-work welfare system we've upset the
natural order okay there is a lot to
unpack there from casually comparing
poor people to animals to claiming that
alligators work which begs the question
the are you talking about
alligators don't have jobs unless you
consider looking like someone put a
dragon baby into a panini press to be a
job in which case yes they are indeed
working 24 7. now the time that Arsenal
was speaking the federal government had
already begun allowing and encouraging
states to experiment with various
so-called welfare to work approaches
with the aim being to get as many people
off government assistance as possible
and in to the workforce and back then
both Democrats and Republican seized on
what appeared to be a successful program
in Riverside County California that
emphasized getting a job Above All Else
and was said to have increased
participants earnings by nearly 50
percent the man overseen that program
Larry Townsend was celebrated at the
time even dubbed the magic bureaucrat
and was brought before Congress to share
the secrets to his success yes if you
call Riverside County and nobody answers
the phone you'll get a work ethic
message we have posters in the waiting
room we have produced a compact disc
with work ethic music one of the the
piece of music is welfare is temporary
not a way of life and it's a beautiful
piece of music
now that is actually true Larry oversaw
the production of this album of work
ethic music that they play in the office
and to people who were put on hold now
is he right to claim that it was a
beautiful piece of music well why don't
you be the judge here's a taste
[Music]
get into it
together you know finally we have a
recording that answers the question what
if we are the world a cheap
motivational poster
and if you think every track on the
album was confined to the genre of Pop
Soul ballad you are very wrong because
they also did a dance number that fair
warning really puts the no into techno
[Music]
I hate it so much that song sounds like
Daft Punk if it turned out the People
Under The Masks were Kevin O'Leary and
Mark Cuban it is genuinely difficult to
stop talking about this album because
what am I supposed to do here just move
on to the rest of this story and not
play you the hip-hop track that would be
ridiculous here it is
wait for me
[Music]
[Applause]
because you can get a job a minute a
minute you thought you knew how bad that
was going to be right then you get to
that last because you can get a job a
bit and it somehow gets worse now
interestingly and importantly later
studies found that that man's program
didn't in fact succeed because of that
album or indeed anything else he'd done
instead research suggests his success
was a fluke and actually the product of
an already stronger local economy rather
than any reforms but the problem was the
whole concept of welfare to work had
caught on in a big way Bill Clinton
campaigned aggressively on welfare
reform and once in office worked with
the Republicans to craft a bill that he
bragged when signing it would move
Millions into the workforce today we are
ending welfare as we know it but I hope
this day will be remembered not for what
had ended but for what it began Now
spoiler alert it's remembered for what
it ended not indeed what it began it is
genuinely hard to think of a clip from
the Clinton era that is aged worse than
that other than of course this one from
his inaugural ball we'll be there for
you we love you thank you and God bless
you all thank you
and thank you Kevin Spacey yeah
yeah
pretty remarkable right that they let
that sexual predator anywhere near Kevin
Spacey the point is
Clinton's welfare reform created the
TANF program and in doing so it brought
about some major and catastrophic
changes first it shifted the funding to
a block grant basically instead of the
federal government having oversight and
sharing the cost of the program each
year it would just give States a lump
sum of money but in doing so it
crucially didn't establish any mechanism
to increase that sum over time meaning
the amount that each state gets has not
increased since 1996 and because it
hasn't been adjusted for inflation or
population changes the real value of the
funding has actually Fallen by 40
percent since then so it wasn't worth
that much in the mid 90s and it's worth
even less doubt think of it like a
single of chumbawambers tubthumping I
don't know if you're under 30 you think
I'm having a stroke right now but I
swear everything I just said is a real
word
the big promise of these block grants
was that they give States the
flexibility to spend it however they
felt worked best for them the only real
requirement was they had to be used for
at least one of four incredibly broad
purposes providing assistance to needy
family so that children can be cared for
in their own homes or in the homes of
relatives fine promoting job preparation
work and marriage okay preventing and
reducing the incidence of out of wedlock
pregnancies seems a bit weird and
encouraging the formation and
maintenance of two parent families so
immediately you can see that not only is
some of that incredibly moralistic it's
crucially a pretty broad mandate and
states have taken advantage of that
latitude for instance some have
appropriated ton of money for college
scholarships that can end up going to
middle class students since 2007
Michigan has spent around 100 million
dollars each year in welfare money on
College Aid much for benefiting families
well above the poverty line and the
state has Justified this by saying that
college aid helps prevent out of wedlock
pregnancies which of course makes sense
doesn't it college is famously a place
where no one meanwhile Oklahoma
was at one point spending millions in
tan of dollars on marriage counseling
classes including one called Forever For
Real would you like to see an ad for it
well too bad here it is
is the most important decision you can
make in your life to marry somebody
so you know who wouldn't want a closer
and stronger relationship once we
decided that we were ready to move
forward in our relationship we wanted to
protect what we had and so we decided to
go to Forever Pharrell for an investment
in us we know that our relationship
won't always be easy but it will be
forever forever for real now
relationships come with instructions
okay first the chemistry between that
couple is very much on the charts
and it doesn't help they tried to set
the Mood by lighting candles when the
rest of the room is lit like the freezer
aisle at a Kroger one reporter attended
one of those classes found participants
were shocked to learn they've been paid
for with welfare dollars because they
consider themselves pretty good and
financially stable but because remember
supporting a two-parent household is one
of the four purposes Tana funds can be
used for what Oklahoma did is completely
legal and while they eventually ended
that program in 2016 that was only after
17 years of spending TANF dollars on it
and it is absolute worst tan of money
can be used in actively harmful ways
like funding crisis pregnancy centers
we've talked about them before on this
show they are basically fake abortion
clinics designed to persuade people to
see pregnancies through to term Often by
propagating misinformation and yet at
least 10 states have siphoned millions
of TANF dollars to pay for them up until
last year Texas had directed 45 million
in TANF funds to these clinics and just
listen to some of the misinformation
that one of them was telling people how
does Center in the Dallas area a
volunteer told our producer they don't
offer abortions adding abortions can
cause infertility when asked about the
abortion pill the volunteer said my job
is not to scare you you never get over
seeing that baby she then pointed to a
small plastic model like this saying can
you imagine one of these in your panties
holy
your tax dollars which were meant to
help poor families instead went to
someone uttering these single grossest
sentence in their history of words the
only proper response to which is can you
imagine how much of a weirdo you'd have
to be to say the word panties to a
stranger while showing them your
collection of Russian nesting fetuses
and look I'm not saying states don't
give any tan of funds to needy families
but in many cases they seem pretty far
down the list of priorities in Oklahoma
sight of those sterile marriage classes
the state was spending just nine percent
of its TANF block grant on cash
assistance and what work states managed
to keep their talent roles incredibly
lean is to set the barrier to access
them insurmountably high in more than 25
States a family of three living at half
the federal poverty line earns too much
to qualify for tanith which is just
absurd just listen to these women in
Mississippi who were told that they were
too rich to qualify we are the people we
are who those programs are supposed to
help and they're not helping us when you
were rejected for TANF for making too
much money how much were you making they
couldn't have been any more than eleven
dollars per hour I was actually making
nine dollars and I was denied how do I
make too much money with three kids rent
utilities
Transportation like how do I make too
much money yeah that is a great question
because it's ridiculous that a parent of
three struggling to make ends meets has
too much money to receive ton of
assistance while the state was more than
happy to shovel cash toward both Brett
Favre and Ted DiBiase a wrestler whose
signature poses hey everyone I just
robbed an ATM
but it's not just that the income
threshold can be prohibitively low is
the application process itself can be
deeply invasive for instance states are
required to offset any tan of money that
they give to single mothers by chasing
down the biological fathers for child
support money that the government then
often keeps for itself so in some states
single mothers applying for public
assistance are forced to identify the
father of their child his eye color his
license plate number and the exact date
when they got pregnant often under
penalty of perjury which is the most
humiliating way to identify the father
of your child that doesn't involve Maori
Povich but there is one more
twist here because even if you qualify
and are able to get assistance it can be
extremely easy to then lose it not only
do some states set time limits for how
long you can get tan if Arizona kicks
you off after just a year the money
comes with an obligation to perform work
activities like job searching and
training the recipients have to engage
in for a certain number of hours each
week but for struggling parents we which
this program is for remember that can be
very difficult especially if they don't
have access to child care and I've lost
the cash assistance three or four times
due to the fact that you know no
Transportation nobody to watch my son
they want you to go looking for work how
do you take a kid into a job and ask for
an application right it's not easy to
take your kid along into a job interview
that is why most job applications don't
come with a bonus big maze and a crayon
and it's not like her state welfare
office is unaware that she has a child
they know that they may even know the
exact date he was conceived for some
reason and if you fail to meet
your obligations States can be pretty
unforgiving in cutting you off just
listen to one woman who was kicked off
assistance despite having an objectively
solid excuse Kimberly Thompson spent two
and a half months in the hospital last
summer after an infection ravaged her
body nearly half of that time she was in
a coma adding insult to injury though
while she was coming the county kicked
her off government assistance well I was
in a coma and I didn't report in this
supposed to report in once a week
so since I didn't report in they just
cut it all off wow finding out you've
lost your government assistance has got
to be one of the worst things you could
possibly hear when waking up for a coma
along with actually we call him
president Trump now and most of the dogs
you knew are dead and the thing is all
of this the multiple Hoops you have to
jump through before getting assistance
and the requirements you have to meet to
keep it is for an abysmally small amount
of money in 15 states cash benefit
levels don't even reach 20 off the
poverty line which is about 386 dollars
for a family of three per month and if
you're thinking well maybe States just
don't have the money not only have you
seen the that some of them
spend it on instead but you should know
perhaps the most shocking thing that
some states spend Talent money on is
absolutely nothing at all as of last
year states were sitting on 5.2 billion
dollars in unspent Tana funds Tennessee
alone was holding 790 million the
largest pool of unspent welfare funds in
the country and you know it's like the
famous saying goes everything's bigger
in Tennessee no wait that's Texas
oh no why is someone writing down
everything I'm saying scratch that from
the record I sound like an idiot why are
you still writing stop I'm serious stop
if you don't stop writing I'll you
up so silly you'll be holding pens in
your mouth Ruth Bader Ginsburg
and when you put all of this together it
is no wonder that most people on TANF
don't in fact go from welfare to work in
2018 only one in four TANF cases closed
because clients found jobs by and large
the rest were kicked off for one of the
many reasons that we've
mentioned tonight basically tanith lifts
people out of poverty the same way one
of those arcade claw games lift stuffed
animals out of the machine which is to
say easily just drops them right back
where they started and in many ways the
whole process is a giant you to
kids
now the good news is there are things
that we could do here if we wanted to
we've talked before about some of the
big broader changes that would help
alleviate the pain of poverty but even
when it just comes to tanith there are
options we could set a minimum benefit
level and loosen some of the
requirements to make it so easy to lose
assistance and if we're going to keep
doing block grants which I would argue
we absolutely shouldn't they should at
least be adjusted for inflation and
population growth with a certain amount
required to be spent on Direct cash
assistance look the wild thing here is
our current system was created under the
assumption that poor families simply
couldn't be trusted to collect welfare
honestly but the past couple of decades
have proven that it's actually
politicians and government officials
who've been relentlessly abusing this
system to borrow a phrase we've been
feeding the alligators in state
government and that has bred dependency
so we need to fundamentally rework
things so that this money and ideally
much more can go where it is badly
needed and if any lawmakers think that
that sounds too hard thought and
attempted to take a pass on it I have a
song with a powerful message that I'm
pretty sure will inspire you
exactly